all right so i'm going to seek the game
and we are about to get paired my
current rating is 1330 we're playing at
12.73
let's jump in folks
[Music]
okay so e4
um
we play e5 on the speed run
uh right now i'm playing kind of the
most basic openings and in chess the
most basic openings are the ones where
you essentially copy your opponent's
move e4 e5 or d4 d5
knight f3
okay so we of course play knight c6 and
bishop b5 this is the roy lopez also
known as the spanish game
this move right here is the most popular
opening at the highest levels of chess
it's been around for
over 500 years in fact it's named after
a priest who lived in the 1500s who was
really the first not the first to
mention this opening in chess literature
but the first to sort of extol the
virtues of bishop e5
now those of you new to chess what white
is doing here is developing their pieces
in the opening stage of the game you
have to get your pieces out of their
initial positions and put them on
squares where they are essentially doing
something
as to what that something is well
there's a lot of things that pieces
could be doing they could be attacking
uh the king which is ultimately the goal
of chess but they they could be doing a
bunch of other stuff that like putting
pressure on pawns and that is what this
bishop is doing it's putting pressure on
the knight the knight is defending the
pawn and so in a indirect way white is
putting pressure on the pawn now we are
going to follow the main line of the roy
lopez we are going to play the move a6
to chase the bishop away from b5
now white has to decide is he going to
take on c6
or is he going to drop the bishop back
to a4 bishop takes c6 is called the
exchange variation
and those of you from charlie's channel
who are you know
new to chess you might be wondering wait
a second what happens if white takes the
knight
we take back and then white grabs this
pawn with his knight right aren't we
blundering upon well as i've showed
before
this is actually a trap and a lot of
beginner players aren't aware of it he
does take on c6 which is a legitimate
move
but let's say let's see if white follows
up by taking this pawn on e5 so which
pawn do we take with
yeah queen d4 very good
which pawn do we take with here well in
order for us to be able to play queen d4
in order for us to be able to move this
queen out to d4
we have to take with the d-pawn now
there is a rule that you should usually
take toward the center i think that rule
is highly overrated but you're often
taught that when you recapture a piece
with a pawn you want to do it in the
direction of the center which would be b
take c6 but
um you always have to weigh the pros and
cons of a move even if a move quote
unquote follows the rules that doesn't
mean it's necessarily good what d take
c6 does is that it opens up the bishop
which allows us to more quickly develop
that bishop to an active square
and more importantly it takes the sting
out of knight takes c5
because we bring our queen up to d4 and
as i'll show after the game
and again those of you new to the
speedrun after the game i basically go
through all of the moves i answer
everybody's questions
and i talk about some of the important
things that didn't happen
because i don't expect everybody to just
visualize stuff in your head and to our
opponent's credit he knows not to take
the ponte castles
he castles
and now of course we have to do
something about
the e5 pawn which is now hanging knight
takes e5 is now a threat we have to
defend the spawn
we have many ways of defending it many
many different ways we can defend it
directly
with a move like f6 or bishop d6 and we
can also defend it indirectly
with uh the move bishop to g4
pinning the knight to the queen
all of these are legitimate moves that i
am going to play the move that
really is the old main line this is the
the move that throughout chess history
has been considered to be the most solid
response to the exchange variation of
the rue lopez and that is the move f6
and i know never play f6 this violates
the sort of very basic rules
of chess development because not only
does you know it's ben feingold cringing
but also
where is this night gonna go are we do
we just not care about developing our
knight well that's why i'm playing this
move because i want to explain a couple
of specific properties of this position
that make the move f6 not only possible
but also quite effective now d4 is the
correct move and this is an important
moment this is an important moment
if we take on d4 right we are
essentially playing into white's hands
because we're opening up the center
and because we played this move f6 right
and you should be understanding this
even if you're a total beginner
right when you play a move like f6 you
are physically weakening the position of
your king in addition we have not yet
developed a single one of our pieces the
piece that we did develop has been
exchanged which means that it is quite
important to keep the center as
closed down as possible or better yet it
would be very nice if we could trade
queens because by trading queens you're
making it less likely that your opponent
is going to checkmate you so
what should we do here who can tell me
the best move for black
and it's a move that i just mentioned a
move ago
now it's time for bishop g4 now we get
our bishop out to g4
the idea is that we pin the knight and
when i say pin a pin is a situation
where
you have a p such as a bishop usually a
bishop
and the bishop pins the knight on f3
which means that the knight cannot move
because behind the knight stands a more
valuable piece okay c3 that is also a
good move
um
had white taken on e5 we would have
traded queens
and then recaptured and i'll talk a
little bit about this end game after the
game
the move c3
reinforces reinforces the d4 pawn
and now
what we have to do with black
is develop our pieces right again
there's nothing extraordinary that we
can do but we do have a really cool move
here which i remember analyzing the main
line
this what most people play is bishop d6
what most people play is bishop d6 and
that's what we're going to do as well
because in the speed run we try to play
solid you know simple chess but bishop
d6 is not the move that i actually play
in my over the board games i will show
the move that i play after the game
all right thank you uh for the sub me on
the gravy knight bd2
all right so our opponent continues
playing very well he could he continues
to develop his pieces
and we should continue to develop our
pieces so what move am i talking about
what does it mean for us to develop our
pieces here well we need to develop the
knight from g8 that's our last remaining
piece that is preventing us from
castling
knight h6 looks pretty awkward you don't
necess you don't usually want to develop
your knights to the rim
you want to develop your knights toward
the center and so we go 97.
and so we go 97 yeah our opponent is
playing all of the top theoretical moves
um so we'll see at what point he
deviates h3
now when you're a beginner uh there's
often a temptation to trade pieces when
you have the chance so
a lot of people are thinking well we
should take the knight on f3 but there's
actually no need to take the knight on
f3 because this bishop on g4 right i
mentioned that it was pinning
white's knight on f3 to the queen so
this is a pretty valuable bishop and so
we can simply drop our bishop back to h5
preserving preserving the pin against
the knight
remember that
retreating moves are never inherently
bad just because they're retrieving
moves
sometimes they're good sometimes they're
bad in this case it is perfectly
acceptable to play bishop h5
now again as a beginner you might be
looking at this and saying well wait a
minute what if white plays pawn to g4
what if white chases that bishop away
well a move like g4 is a move where you
push upon in front of your own king when
you push pawns in front of your own king
the king becomes more exposed and those
pawns become easier to attack so g4
would be playing right into our hands
all right so
d e we simply take back with the f one
and i think here
queen b3 is
the theoretical move if i'm not mistaken
i already don't know the theory here so
um let's see what our opponent does
knight c4 is also very good
all right
well um
let's figure out what to do in this
position
let's figure out what to do in this
position
the problem that i'm seeing
is that oh there's no problem i think we
just castle
i think we just castle and we are not
blundering our bishop because our c7
pawn is guarding that bishop on d6
all right
so far i think we're still following
main line theory
now what's happening here in this
position what's going on well
you might notice that
by castling we're exerting more pressure
on
the rook on the knight on f3
and in fact we were still pitting that
knight but queen b3 is a very powerful
move
what it does is that it sets up an x-ray
against our king
the second thing that it does is that it
unpins the knight which means that the
knight can now move
without fear of losing white's queen
now what is our top priority here well
our priority is to get rid of this x-ray
and x-ray leads to a discovered check in
many cases white is threatening to take
on d6 with the knight and that will be
checked that's a devastating check so
you might say well let's move our king
to h8 but that doesn't address the
second problem he's going to take on e5
in that case the question then becomes
can we address both problems at the same
time can we
cut into the x-ray while also protecting
the pawn on e5 and the answer is yes we
can bring our bishop back to f7 the
problem with this move is that he has
the move knight g5 in response which is
very strong
uh we will see if he plays it
but uh the point is that yes he does
play it
uh but i have an idea here
i have an idea i think that
oh wait a minute there there there there
there there there thank you spaceship
trucker appreciate it
okay
let me think folks i have to remember
the theory
so what is the purpose of knight q5 the
purpose of nigeria 5 is to immediately
contest the bishop on f7
if we take the knight on c4 then he's
going to take back with a queen and that
combination of the queen and the knight
uh is going to be very devastating
so
we need to be the ones to allow white to
take our bishop
and we somehow have to defend the pawn
on b7 i honestly don't remember
what the top move is here
what comes to mind for me is the move b5
what comes to mind for me is the move b5
attacking the knight
and forcing him to take the bishop on f7
folks
simmer down on the cheating accusations
if i get suspicious as i say every time
i will share with you
uh the moment that i become suspicious i
will be honest about it but there is no
need to just say you know 500 times that
he's cheating one way or another we're
going to determine that after the game
and it's important to give people the
benefit of the doubt during the game
okay so rook takes f7 recapturing the
knight by the way notice that if we
would have taken the other knight he
takes the queen on d8
and then we take his queen
and then he escapes via e6 so he plays
knight takes d6
now which pawn or sorry which piece
should we capture with should we take
with the queen or should we take with
the pawn
we should definitely take with the pawn
and the reason why is that we need to
improve our pawn structure what does it
mean to improve your pawn structure well
if you look at this position
the pawn on e5 is not surrounded by any
other pawns right it's they're all alone
and that's called an isolated pawn and
you want to try to avoid isolated pawns
when possible and so by taking on d6 of
the pawn you are essentially connecting
these two puns you're making sure that
the e5 pawn is well protected
and at this point i i still think that
this is probably common common theory i
would be concerned about the move a4
here
i would okay between e6
queen e6 is also
a pretty dangerous move he gets right
into our grill
and he's probably going to follow up
with the move rook d1
he's probably going to follow up with
him with rook t1 attacking the pawn on
d6
uh so what we need to do is we need to
immediately activate
this rook on a8 and prepare
to get it to d8 in order to protect the
pawn on d6
we cannot move our we cannot move our
rook we cannot move our rook because the
rook is pinned so i would play queen c7
here i don't love our position i think i
did something wrong
what worries me is if he goes rook d1
and then he induces rook d8 and then at
some point white goes a4
at some point white might go a4 and try
to open up a second front
let's see what he does
so i'll be honest whether or not i'm
suspicious is going to be determined
in the next couple of moves right now i
feel like
it's totally plausible that he knew all
of this theory if he goes a4 here i'll
be a little bit
a little bit suss but
with that being said that does not mean
i'm accusing him of cheating or anything
of the sort
okay so a4 is a very strong move because
it opens up the a file
and why is opening up the a file a
a good idea because our rook has left
the a file which means that if white
trades pawns on b5 he's gonna have an
uncontested open file for his rook by
the way i hope i'm explaining things
relatively clearly there's a lot to talk
about and
you know this game has been played on a
pretty high level
so if you're a beginner you know i hope
that it hasn't been too overwhelming
after the game i'll talk about some of
the concepts in more rudimentary detail
okay
and he goes b3
b3 now that is not a move that struck me
as particularly scary
but i guess it makes sense i think
white's idea is to get this bishop to a3
and continue to pressure the d6 pawn
now the thing is
i feel like we should trade queens here
i really feel like we should get this
queen
out of the way right off of e6 and we
can force a queen trade how can we force
a queen trade
how can we force a queen trade
yeah so not queen c8 if we go queen c8
we relinquish our control of the d6 pawn
he can take the pawn with the rook
so we have to go queen d7 this
keeps the d6 spawn protected and it
offers a queen trade which white cannot
refuse because white's queen simply has
no squares
thank you for the bits
okay so takes takes
and i'm anticipating bishop a3 here or
a4
a4 would be particularly annoying here
uh now that we're in the end game and my
pawns are kind of weak
let's see what happens
why not queen b6 well because oh there's
a4
all right
well let's think
let's think
so why is a4 a good move let's let's uh
deconstruct what's going on here white
wants to take on b5
and then that rook's going to have a
wide open a file and rook can move to a6
or a8 and put a lot of pressure on our
position
now there's nothing i can do about it
because taking the pawn on a4 it makes
matters even worse he takes with the
rook and then we're going to have a
tremendously weak pawn on a6 which we
simply cannot defend
so
[Music]
what we have to do is try to improve our
position right we have to make some sort
of a neutral move
and one thing that we could try to do is
is a move like rocafe in order to
preemptively
in order to preemptively prevent white's
rook from getting to a8
does that make sense after he takes on
b5
we're trying to cover a couple of
crucial squares with our rooks a7 and a8
he goes bishop a3
not the move i was expecting
but it also makes sense he attacks the
pawn on d6
we go well we don't want to pre-move
that we go rook fda we defend the pawn
and our next two moves are going to be
to bring that king all the way to e6
and over protect the d6 pawn he goes c4
i feel like he's going off the rails
just a little bit c4
c4
all right well um
do we have to do anything do we have to
react to this move do we should we take
should we take
well there's a pro and a con to taking
right if we trade
the issue that i'm seeing is that it
opens up the b file for white
and rook b1 rook b6 becomes a very nasty
idea so what i would do is leave the
pawn on b5
and let him be the one to take
everything
but
from a third perspective that allows
white to open the a file i actually
think c4 is a tremendous move
i i want to make a waiting move but i
want to make a healthy waiting room i
don't just want to go h6 if we're making
a waiting live i would i want to bring
my king up to e6
um i can't really decide whether it's a
good idea to take on c4 or not
maybe takes on c4 and then c5 makes
sense
but then again he goes rook b1 and tries
to get the rook to b6 that looks very
nasty
all right
let's go king f7 let's see what he does
what i'm worried about here is a trade
on b5 and then
well we'll see what he does after that
the immediate bishop before also looks
pretty scary
all right
yeah this has been a good game i i think
that black is fine i i don't think that
i'm in mortal danger of losing the game
just yet
okay so takes we we take toward the
center here in this case now we don't
want to take with the c pawn because
then uh the a6 pawn remains in the line
of fire of the rook it doesn't matter
because at the end of the day we traded
everything
and let's see what white comes up with
here
let's see what white comes up with here
there's no question that he's playing on
the level of a gm so far but i would
also say that most of his moves have
been
not obvious but
definitely findable
and it doesn't seem to me that he's
played necessarily the top move so far
i'm not getting that kind of sense
the moves have been have been findable
the other thing is
if he goes bishop b4 here
then we can swing the knight out to c6
and chase that bishop away he goes rook
c1
that's a good move
let's go king e6 let's centralize our
king it's the end game
the end game is a loosely defined term
which means the final stage of the game
generally it's when queens are off the
board and there's only a couple of
pieces remaining for each side
and in the end game
because there are no queens on the board
you have to activate your king
all right so he goes bishop b4
and we're definitely worse i mean no
question that black is worse here we got
to be careful
so what ideas
could we propose here well what is the
idea of bishop before
maybe he'll go back to a1 and then a6 so
one idea is to move the stroke to a8 and
beat him to the punch
i actually think that's what we're going
to do let's go rook a8
now notice that
you know we're keeping the stroke on the
a file we're keeping this other rook as
a defending piece because we cannot
afford to lose the d6 pawn
i do have an idea so far
i do have an idea
and the idea is to chase the bishop away
from before who can propose this idea
who sees a way that you can prepare to
chase the bishop away from before
yeah but you can't play knight c6
immediately you can't play this move
immediately
you can't play this move immediately
what what do we start with
why because it blunders the knight his
rook on c1 guards the square so we have
to play rook a6 that was my idea and
then follow up with knight c6
rook a6
and then knight c6
and that bishop is going to be chased
away from before i actually think that
we're playing this very well
king h2 wow
okay
well
let's follow our plan
i mean i don't understand these moves h3
king h2 is like
strange it doesn't even seem that scary
i honestly just don't get it
okay now we're making progress we're
making progress
we're making progress
how should we continue here so a couple
of you are suggesting before i don't
understand why you're so attracted to b4
before he drops the bishop back to b2
no rather i would i would target this
pawn immediately
let's target the pawn on b3
let's let's let's get get that pawn
now some of you might say wait wait a
minute there's an x-ray on the knight on
c6
can't white play bishop b2
simultaneously hitting the rook and then
hitting the knight on c6
well what's black's response there
what happens after bishop b2
yeah the rook takes the pawn there
should be two of the rook takes the pawn
and if the rook takes the knight then we
can take the bishop on b2 and we emerge
a pawn up
b4
okay well i'm not done hunting for that
pawn on b3
and very often in the end game there
will be situations where you have
essentially two two ways to do the same
thing
and we have rook a4 and we have rook b3
well i see what i think he wants to do
there there's a detail here that i
missed if rook b3 has got rook d5
oh but then we can maybe play rook b7
then we can maybe play rookie seven
let's give it a shot let's see what he
what he has in mind
why is rook d5 scary because it attacks
the pawn on b5 and so if we play knight
takes b4 then rook takes b5 and r knight
is then going to be pinned to the rook
on b3
but
after rook d5 we can
if we want to defend
the pawn on b
on b5 with the move rook b7 the drawback
of that move is that it leaves the d6
pawn now without a defender
but
the white rook will not be able to leave
c1 c1 because the bishop on c3 is going
to be hanging king g3
okay this is a strange move i think
our opponent might be losing the threat
of the game obviously we take the pawn
on b4
obviously we take the pawn on before
this still should be a draw the game
should still end in the draw even though
we're a pawn up because we've got a
bunch of weaknesses in our position this
pawn is weak white's rooks are active
but
now we have an extra pawn
and the way he's been playing the last
couple of moves i feel like we might be
able to grind the snap grind this out
yeah we'll take a look after the game
uh with an engine to see like what was
going on now what should be the strategy
in this position
it's still a draw i mean if white is
careful then he should be able to make a
draw without problems and rook d5 is
excellent
yeah i mean we have to push the passer
we have to push the passer
now we can't push it because the rook is
on before we have to move the rook out
of the way
we have to move the rook out of the way
now where should we move it and this is
where a tricky moment occurs because if
you move the rook to b2
you're going to get a situation
where once the pawn
advances to b3 again we're going to have
the same issue the rook on b2 is going
to be in the way of the pawn does that
make sense
so we need to use tactics and use our
creativity to figure out a way
in where we can somehow
get this rook off of the b-file so that
the pawn has a clear path forward
so i came up with a move rook b7 first
but that move doesn't work and that's
the brilliance of how he's playing
because he goes rook to c6 and hits the
pawn on d6 forcing a rook back a lot of
you are suggesting rook c4 i thought of
that move initially but that leads to a
draw that leads to a draw
uh because he goes rook b1 let's test
him on this let's test him on this rook
b2 is a much more straightforward draw
let's see whether he finds this and he
does rook b1
we go before it looks like we're home
free but no we're not he goes rook b5
and he picks up the pawn on b4 and the
result of this is a dead drawn end game
which i will try to win because maybe he
will
let's say
let his guard down a little bit
and we will see if
that
leads us anywhere good
okay so this is the draw this is a four
on four all right guys relax everybody
relax
we will analyze the game with the
computer
and we will determine
whether he's suss or not so nobody needs
to freak out at the moment
okay
now this is a draw
but in fact if i were playing this with
white i would prefer white just because
we have a slightly discombobulated pawn
structure we can offer a draw here or we
can just make a couple of moves let's
see let's go over c7 i'll offer a draw
i'll offer a draw
and that draw offer is
accepted that was a variable play game
um
now i see in his game history that he
has
wins and losses
against 1200s
so first thing i'm going to do is i'm
going to check the accuracy and i'm
going to look
look at look at the accuracy
the accuracy might not be as high as we
think it is it was very high it was 95
to 95.
um let's see some of the key moves now
how do i determine and maybe we'll use
this as a
as a window to
looking at
um
you know
for me explaining to you guys how i
would go about
testing a game let's say if i'm
suspicious of it
so am i suspicious yes i mean i'm
definitely suspicious 1200s don't
usually play
you know to this quality but that
there's a difference between being
suspicious and then accusing somebody
of cheating
which should not be done without very
clear-cut evidence
and that evidence can come in the form
of comparing the game with the engine
analysis which we're going to do right
now
okay
so
it was an exchange rule lopez
it was an exchange rule lopez
and what i just wanted to show you guys
is that if white plays knight takes e5
here
particularly those of you who are new to
chess there's a very important detail
which is the black has queen d4
this is a fork a fork is essentially an
attack against two pieces or
more and um
the knight has to move white has to save
the night and then we take the pawn and
that's also a check and not only is that
a check no queen e7 is not better
not only is that a check
it's a check that forces white to lose
castling rights either to move the king
to f1 uh
which is yucky or better to play queen
e2 queen e2 king e2 and again black has
two bishops which is really good white
is only one bishop and why black is
better here i mean black is slightly
better
it's just a great position the king is
weak so just remember this if you're an
e5 player
okay so he played castles which is the
main line f6
d4
bishop g4
c3
now notice that this engine suggests
queen e7 that is the move which i
actually play myself queen e7 in my
opinion is the best move
it's showing an advantage for white but
take that with a grain of salt i i think
the black is fine in this line
uh okay
so
essentially
i we played bishop d6 which is the old
old school move which is the old school
move
uh defending defending the pawn on e5
and let's just start by
running the game with an engine and
seeing
whether he played like an engine in
critical moments so knight b 297
h3 is top bishop h5
and and what we're looking for is we're
looking at the top two suggestions if he
plays within the top two or even within
the top three suggestions for the whole
game yeah that's suspicious d5 top
knight c4 top
and here
okay queen b3
appears as the top move
knight g5 is obvious i mean this i don't
really fault him for take stakes
now he played the move queen e6 which
um
was briefly in the list yeah now it's
number three
now it's number three uh so definitely a
good move but maybe not necessarily the
best move
queen c7
rook d1 is essentially the top move you
can see hey four rook d1 and bishop e3
are basically equivalent
rook d8
yeah now he plays v3 which is
an inaccuracy this is not an engine move
for sure
queen d7 takes takes
now he goes a4 which is top
bishop a3
is
bishop e3 is you know also
not really the top move but one of the
top moves
yeah c4 is the top move that move made
me suspicious the move c4 here
is a really hard move to play i mean
you're basically accepting that all of
your pawns are going to be weak
and that's an incredibly high level move
being f7 a b a b
c b c b now he goes okay c 1 which is
also the top move bishop b4 is also the
top move yeah this is incredibly
suspicious i mean this move is also just
not at the level of you know 1200 but
then he played f3
and we found a very very nice move rook
a6 oh and king h2 is the top move too
king h2 you can see is like number two
now bishop c3 now we did have d5 here
which maybe yielded slightly better
chances here
b4 is inaccurate
but then he responds with the move king
g3
which is the second move
and i should have gone patiently with
the move rook b7 instead i took on b4
which leads to equality and he plays
rook d5 very
very accurate
yeah i mean
look i'll put it this way very very high
probability that he selectively cheated
um
he's 1274. some of these moves were just
you know they were played on the level
of a gm you know queen even queen e6 is
a really nice move rook d1 b3 is another
idea like b3 a4 c4
just extremely you know high level
positional play in the end game
uh is do i have you know do i have
evidence that is presentable in court no
and that's what's very important to
understand it's like
that's why chess.com has their
anti-cheating methods
and that's why if you believe someone is
cheating you should report them and
chess.com will investigate them
another thing to realize is even if i
report somebody that doesn't mean that
they're going to be necessarily accused
they're going to be necessarily
convicted of it chess.com treats all
accusations equally of course i can
streamline it
uh but it's not like anybody gets
preferential treatment
and nor should anybody get preferential
treatment
how sustain i would give it a 95 percent
chance
belief that he cheated
um
you know to me that that's what it seems
like to me or that he's
extremely underrated and you know his
actual rating should be 24 2500.
if it's a gm i would believe it but it's
clearly not a gm because he plays at
this level for most of his games
okay
yeah i just want to be very very clear
about what i am saying what i'm not
saying you know if he's listening to
this
and you know
what i what i would hope is that even if
he's listening to this he would still
understand where i'm coming from based
on
you know what i'm showing to be the
engine moves
so
in any case that was a pretty high level
game i mean it was a rai lopez basically
as a result of the opening we didn't get
too many winning chances just the way
that he played in the opening really
shut me down
um and
yeah i guess we can look at his other
games or at least let's look at his loss
let's look at his loss
and let's see like what his opening play
is like
okay so bishop d2
okay already he's black he's black in
this game
i mean e5 e4 this guy's this guy's just
good
jesus i mean he is very good
but
yeah this game is also weird but he lost
it in the end i mean
what is going on here this rook is
hanging on c3
i would guess his actual strength if
he's not cheating is probably 23 2400
standard
um
for sure
okay but look at this
look at this bishop takes c3 no i mean
obviously this is
i mean he's just blundering all of his
pieces so
yeah something is going on here guys but
i don't really want to explore it
further i still think that was a good
game um and there's definitely stuff to
analyze so
i don't want to bog us down too much
with that
it is what it is guys but i'm gonna call
it a night i am exhausted
i'll see you guys later thanks again
goodbye
[Music]